P
OUT BY INCREASING PRODUCTION.
>> Todd: LET US BRING IN JOE
CONCHA, YOU HEARD ALEXANDRIA
HOFF'S PIECE, THERE IS A RECEIVE
HEIDI HEITKAMP IS FORMER NORTH
DAKOTA SENATOR, SHE IS FROM
NORTH DAKOTA, WHERE THE OIL
COMES FROM.
JENNIFER RUBIN OF THE
"WASHINGTON POST" TWEETING,
VOTERS IN A STUPID NUT SHELL,
70% DISAPPROVE OF BIDEN HANDLES
OF GAS PRICES.
BANNING RUSSIAN OIL MEANS PAYING
MORE AT THE PUMP.
COMMON THEME FROM BOTH
STATEMENTS, IT IS OUR FAULTS,
NOT THE FAULT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, WHY IS MIDDLE
CLASS ALWAYS TO BLAME WHEN IT
COMES TO ELITES?
>> Joe: MIDDLE CLASS AND
OBVIOUSLY FOLKS POORER THAN
THAT, WHO CAN'T AFFORD THESE
SORT OF PRICE INCREASES AT THE
PUMP BECAUSE THEN THEY ARE
MAKING DECISION BETWEEN GAS AND
FOOD, RIGHT? INFLATION IS
HITTING THAT SECTOR, AS WELL, OR
HOME HEATING COSTS HAVE GONE UP
IN SOME CASES 50%.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY SOMEBODY WHO
LIVES IN THE IVORY TOWERS OF THE
"WASHINGTON POST" OR NEAR THERE
IN WASHINGTON, ESHG LITIST IS
GEN RUBIN.
SHE CALLS FOR RULES THAT WOULD
PREVENT MEDIA OUTLETS -- SHE
CALLED TRUMP SUPPORTERS A BASKET
OF DEPLORABLES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN PROMISED NO MORE
DRILLING OFF SHORE OR DRILLING
FOR THE OIL INDUSTRY TO DRILL.
HE KILLED DRILL NOTHING ALASKA
AND EXPANSION OF THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE AND CONTINUED
RHETORICAL WAR ON U.S. OIL
COMPANIES ACCUSING THEM OF PRICE
GOUGING, BUT CAN YOU HELP US OUT
BEFORE WE DESTROY YOUR INDUSTRY?
IT IS AMAZING.
JEN RUBIN, "WASHINGTON POST,"
DEFENDING JOE BIDEN AND MAKING A
FOOL OF HERSELF.
>> Carley: KAMALA HARRIS'S TRIP
TO POLAND, WHERE SHE LAUGHED
WHILE DISCUSSING UKRAINIAN
REFUGEES, HERE IS HOW A PANEL
DESCRIBED THAT MOMENT, WATCH
THIS.
>> SHE WAS STRONG AND ARK
CERTIVE AND THIS WOMAN IN THE
SENATE HAD SENATORS SHOOK.
>> THIS IS SOMEBODY USED TO
TAKING ON BAD GUYS FOR A LIVING.
>> Carley: IT IS LIKE THEY WERE
WATCHING SOMETHING TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THAN THE REST OF
AMERICA.
>> Joe: INTERESTING ANALYSIS,
ONE POINT THEY SAID KAMALA
HARRIS SHOOK SENATORS OR SHOOK
WILLIAM BARR.
THE IMPLICATION IS VLADAMIR
PUTIN IS NOW SHAKING, WHY
BECAUSE THE VICE PRESIDENT
AWKWARDLY SAID A FRIEND IN NEED
AND A FRIEND INDEED, THE THIRD
PART OF THE SONG, A FRIEND WITH
WEED IS BETTER AND PROCEEDS TO
CACKLE AFTER THAT.
SHE READ NOTES ABOUT SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR SYRIA AND
RUSSIA AND EVIL ACTION SAYS
OTHERWISE IN THE SHAKING
DEPARTMENT AND HE TARGETING
CIVILIANS AND MOTHERS,
JOURNALLIN
JOURNALISTS AND DOESN'T APPEAR
TO BE STOPPING, ONLY INCREASING
DESPITE HOW STRONG KAMALA HARRIS
LOOKS.
>> Carley: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, WE'LL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
>> Joe: THAT SONG IS BY PLACEBO
FROM 1998, PLAY IT WHEN YOU ARE
WORKING OUT LATER CARLEY AND
TODD, IT IS EXCELL